there's a movement
a community of people referred to as
bitcoin maximalists
i've seen you referred at least in the
past as the leader
of uh
of the bitcoin maximalist probably
because of your book you know bitcoin
standard consider the bible in general
you're one of the leaders in this space
do you regret any of the toxicity and
derision that
often or perhaps sometimes originates
from this community
um definitely not i'm not in the
position to regret other people's
actions so let's just be clear
i think the rhetoric of community is um
i reject this rhetoric because i think
it's um
it's a way for kind of
political manipulation and uh subversion
to try and
um portray people as part of a community
and hold people responsible for other
people's actions which i think is
ridiculous so you know some guy on the
internet said something mean to somebody
and then this is very common and it's i
i always try and not get involved in
these things so some guy who identifies
as a bitcoiner says something to
somebody that's very wrong of course it
happens
tens of millions of people use bitcoin
around the world
and a lot of these i'd say parasites you
know people who don't have anything
productive to do with their life um you
know outrage merchants they'll come out
and say something along the lines of you
know the bitcoin maximalists are um
toxic they're holding bitcoin back and
they need and of course it's
manipulative the point behind it is they
want to get to you to they want to get
people who are you know not that nobody
with 300 followers who said something
silly they want to get the notable
people uh to basically change their
message so the idea is
you know i'm supposed to apologize
because somebody with 300 followers i've
never met in my life who calls
themselves a bitcoiner said a mean word
and then i need i need to apologize and
i also need to cut down on my rhetoric
about other digital currencies and i
need to do that so
i i'm only responsible for my own
actions and
i don't recall regretting anything
okay but let me push back or push
further into that direction fine let's
see community aside labels suck
for sure
but you have a spicy way
about you on twitter
uh even in this conversation you know
you had some uh
some good strong words
i've always believed
life is too short to mince words one day
i'm gonna be dead and i'm on my deathbed
i'm not gonna look back and say
i wish i was a little bit more
circumspect in expressing my opinions
i'm far more likely to think you know
what i wish i said what i really think
yes life is too short to hold back your
opinion the question is
what is really your opinion because
you're uh
you're many people in one
so there's a person that loves there's
kindness for other human beings as a
person that gets annoyed there's a
person that enjoys this agreement as a
person that enjoys collaboration and you
can emphasize all of those different
things each of those different things
weigh it differently in your online
interaction
there are some aspects of online
interaction that encourages
in different communities online
interaction is one community that
encourages kind of derision and mockery
and so on so you get you can choose if
you want to engage that part of yourself
or some other part of yourself economics
is another community
that enjoys
being like very straightforward about
their disagreements pretty harsh
it's fun to watch because it feels like
you arrive at the truth much faster
because you tear each other apart
um but
uh you know that that's a choice that's
a deliberate choice and you mean i don't
want to label an entire community of
people by its extremes i don't think you
should do that but there's cultural
characteristics you start to notice when
you go to france that's a certain way
when you go to britain london is
different than rural alberta and you
know new york is different than
iowa you start to notice things i mean
you don't want to generalize there's all
kinds of people everywhere but
you know there's a certain way of
communication on crypto twitter in
general but also
bitcoin maximalist that i even early on
received a bunch of heat it's what the
hell
so it listen there's definitely a
difference when i go to the computer
science community machine learning
community
uh it's way friendlier than the
cryptocurrency community um i have much
more freedom to actually
be what i enjoy being which is um asking
simple dumb questions even when i've
already spent
years sometimes decades with an idea i
like asking dumb questions anyway uh the
crypto folks punish you for this
for curiosity for
um
like exploration i understand the
mechanism because so many other people
come into that community
and they might masquerade
as
curious but really they're trying to
inject they're trying to sell some kind
of altcoin there's some scheme there's
some scheme to make money and so
i understand maybe that's just the
dynamics of the community by nature it's
not like
you respond appropriately to the amount
of
charlatans in the community so if the
fraction of charlatans is low maybe you
can afford to be more loving and kind
and so on and when the fraction of
charlatans is high you have to be
harsher
perhaps
perhaps but i think also you know the
stakes are extremely high in this
situation and i think you know if you
don't like bitcoiners if you think
bitcoins are toxic wait till you meet
theaters you know
the fiat community has financed world
wars and genocides and
tyrants and um the mass death and
destruction the fiat community if you
want to use that term i don't believe
you should but i mean you know fiat has
destroyed the savings of pretty much
anybody who's lived through the last
20th century pretty much anybody who's
lived through the 20th century no matter
where you lived switzerland us ethiopia
russia you've gone through
fiat problems you've had hyperinflation
you've had bank confiscation
there isn't a family in the world today
that hasn't had its wealth destroyed
over the last century you know they all
have a story about the inflation and the
hyperinflation and bitcoin offers us a
way out of this and um [ __ ] coins
altcoins
are uh
essentially fiat world's uh
last gasp attempt to try and salvage
fiat to try and salvage the idea that
some people will continue to be able to
print money and other people will have
to use that money
you know
this is twitter it's a free market it's
the internet you don't have to follow
anybody that's the thing like so
i what i found what i find really
objectionable about the people who are
so butthurt always about bitcoin
maximalists is
you don't have to click follow on people
you don't like there are 300 million
twitter accounts
and if you choose to follow the accounts
that say things that annoy you and then
complain about the fact that they say
things that annoy you
i'm sorry but you're an idiot that you
don't know how to use twitter
just follow the accounts that you like
it's it's
you know you don't have to be part of
this you don't have to listen to those
people you can choose there are a lot of
bitcoiners that don't act like this you
can just unfollow the ones that you're
like
since in the past
year man time flies i've met a lot of
them i enjoy them a lot and you build
that community of people that you enjoy
they're less than communicating the way
you enjoy and uh it's becoming meme at
this point that i i block with love i
think yes because i did not
i block very prolifically and i strongly
recommend people continue to block i
think twitter is you know you're not
going to get to interact with 300
million accounts anyway so you want to
be constantly curating the experience by
getting rid of people you don't like and
following people that you like and
that's just how you know after 10 years
of using twitter you know you get you
accumulate the block list which is very
big which i'm very happy for i'm going
to pass on to my children
it's in your deathbed your grandchildren
will gather around and
your grandfather can finally share yeah
the full list
yeah so like again it's just a twitter
account if it bothers you so much ask
yourself why it bothers you that some
people are so i'm not referring to you
obviously but i mean the people that are
constantly aggravated about this i don't
get bothered by anything on twitter i
just block immediately and i get to
curate the experience that i enjoy and i
recommend people do that
it's really a lot less pathetic than
complaining about strangers saying
things you don't like which a lot of um
and of course the reason for it is you
know i mean when i say it's stupid it's
not really stupid there's an ulterior
motive there then the ulterior motive is
hey i have this [ __ ] coin that i made
with five other friends of mine and i'd
like you to i'd like to write your
codetails bitcoiners and i'd like you to
please help me promote this [ __ ] like
this i i get this
practically every week whether through
email or through twitter where hey you
know this is our [ __ ] coin um you know
it's just like bitcoin but it's better
because it does this and this and that
and you know basically how can we get
you to promote this [ __ ] coin for us
and
being straightforward and forthright is
a great
productivity hack because um you know
you just tell those people no i'm not
interested it's a stupid [ __ ] coin and i
wish you a quick and swift failure
before you take a lot of people's money
um and that's what i genuinely think
well but i'll just be upfront with the
fact at least for my taste just labeling
everything as a [ __ ] coin
worries me uh so this is my own
preference it's not a judgment on you
it's it's just my own preference that
i'm afraid i'll miss good ideas um i
think when you're me personally when i'm
too certain about things
when i um too tribal about things i'll
miss actually
really strong ideas outlier ideas
totally new ideas so that that worries
me one of
the downsides of the way
bitcoin is how much it is at stake
financially is that it's less open to
good actually by design that it's not
changing like with the hard forks and so
on that there's not a kind of curiosity
about exploration of ideas
of course
in some way that curiosity can start
getting ejected when you start talking
about other layers built on top of
bitcoin you start talking about
applications or different things like
lightning network that's where the
curiosity can emerge
but still like that's why with with
cryptocurrency in general i just tried
to keep an open mind and just the [ __ ]
coin
as a term is just like a statement that
i'm going to close my mind to it that's
the way i hear it
and uh but coming out of your mouth
because you say a lot of other edgy
stuff it's just more you having fun
that's the way i hear but if i said
something like that that's uh i feel
like i would feel like i'm closing my
mind i mean let me give you the counter
argument to that how much time do you
spend emailing back all these nigerian
prince email scams that you know email
you tell you send me five thousand
dollars and i'll send you 15 million
dollars none
none why are you being closed-minded to
all of these great ideas no but i'm also
you know maybe one of them will actually
send you 15 million but i don't know if
i know the difference between the
nigerian prince
and many other people i do talk to who
are colleagues and so on that are also
emailing me and they're also
offering me things but they don't sound
as ridiculously spammy yeah but i mean
the moment that somebody tells you hey
i'm gonna give you 15 million dollars
for nothing just if you send me five
thousand dollars you know you're getting
something for nothing and essentially
with all the digital currencies
it's the same pitch say hey you know
come use this thing that'll allow you to
do things that all of the things that
they pretend that they can do that can
be done with computers without having
digital currencies you know we already
have aws that does cloud computing that
does everything that [ __ ] coins pretend
to do
the only difference is aws doesn't have
its own monetary system tacked on top of
it to allow jeff bezos to basically
print his own money
you